-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show"!
You're here! You made it!
Thank you for watching.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Well, it seems like there's
so much going on right now.
Tropical depression Henri
is still hitting the Northeast,
NBA champs the Seattle Storm
visited Biden
at the White House,
the pumpkin spice latte is back,
and a woman found nuts and bolts
in her Domino's pizza.
[ Laughter ]
There's a lot to go over,
so let's just jump in
and cover it all at once.
It's time for a "News Mash."
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
First up, the WNBA champions
the Seattle Storm.
[ Cheering and applause ]
They visited President Biden
today and get this --
they're the first WNBA team
to be invited to the White House
since 2015.
[ Cheering and applause ]
It's a pretty big deal.
Speaking of storms
that are a pretty big deal,
tropical depression Henri.
[ Laughter ]
Over the weekend,
45 million people were
under a tropical storm warning,
so, last week, things on the
East Coast were hot and sticky
and, this week,
things were just wet.
[ Laughter ]
And if you want something
that's just hot, wet,
and sticky, why not try
Starbucks' pumpkin spice latte?
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's back.
Starting tomorrow.
Some people are excited,
while others think
it's too early
for pumpkin spice.
Either way, drinking one
is way better than
eating a pizza covered
in nuts and bolts.
A woman reportedly ate half
of her Domino's Pizza
before finding them
in her toppings.
Can you imagine digesting
all that cheese and metal?
I mean, that would rock you
like a...
hurricane that was
[ Laughter ]
downgraded
to a tropical depression.
Sure, it doesn't feel good
to be demoted,
but keep your head up, Henri.
[ Laughter ]
If you work hard
and do your best,
you, too, can be the
Storm invited
to the White House.
[ Laughter ]
The team took pictures
with the Bidens
and, of course, a lot of the
players are taller than them.
And, if you want something tall,
that's from Seattle, why not try
Starbucks' pumpkin spice latte.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's only five bucks
for a tall.
So, it'll be on the house,
if you
find nuts and bolts in it.
[ Laughter ]
If that woman sues Domino's,
she could probably
make a lot of money.
I bet she could even
make it rain.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Henri broke the record
for rainfall
in one hour in New York,
which is nuts.
And bolts.
[ Laughter ]
In conclusion,
OMG,
FYI,
PSL!,
FML.
[ Cheering and applause ]
This has been a "News Smash."
♪♪
[ Whistling ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
Thank you very much.
Wow.
[ Applause ]
Here's some good news --
today, the FDA granted
full approval
to Pfizer's COVID vaccine.
[ Cheering and applause ]
It's about time!
Their statement started with,
"Hey, sorry, I just saw this."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it was approved
by the real FDA,
the Food and Drug
Administration,
which is not to be confused
with the fake FDA,
the Facebook Doctors
Association.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah!
-Yeah, this is great news,
although,
if it didn't get approved,
I'm not really sure
what the options were.
[ Laughter ]
Pfizer store credit?
Must be weird,
working at the FDA.
One day, you're approving
a lifesaving vaccine;
the next, you're approving
new S'mores-flavored Oreos.
[ Laughter ]
Get this -- Which I don't
believe is a real thing,
but, if it is --
-If it isn't, it should be.
-Yeah, I would -- yeah.
I'd get the shot and the cookie,
yeah, both.
[ Laughter ]
Get this -- the new name of the
fully approved Pfizer vaccine is
Comirnaty.
[ Laughter ]
Comirnaty, which sounds more
like a drunk person trying
to say, "Community."
[ Laughter ]
[ Slurring words ]
You can't arrest me.
I'm a valued member
of the community.
[ Laughter ]
[ Hiccough ]
[ Applause ]
But the vaccine isn't
the only thing keeping
the FDA busy.
They recently had to tell people
not to treat COVID
with a drug that's given
to animals with worms.
[ Laughter ]
This is real. They tweeted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
Meanwhile, the people
taking it are like --
[ Southern accent ]
Laugh all you want,
but I don't have COVID
and the worms are
almost gone, so.
[ Laughter ]
Some entertainment news --
well, due to his past
offensive comments,
Mike Richards has stepped down
as host of "Jeopardy!",
after just one day of filming.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, he was only the host
for five shows.
Come on. Half the contestants
last longer than he did.
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
he's stepping down as host,
but he'll remain as the show's
executive producer.
Not a great look on his résumé.
It's like having your jobs
listed as Wendy's cashier,
Wendy's manager,
Wendy's cashier.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, Mike Richards
has stepped down as host,
but he's already taped
a week's worth of episodes.
Not surprisingly, the categories
are pretty awkward.
Take a look.
-Here are the categories
in the Jeopardy! round...
♪♪
And, finally...
[ Laughter ]
-Interesting.
[ Applause ]
And, finally, inspired
by a recent TikTok trend,
a Domino's in Australia
has unveiled
a unusual new menu item.
Take a look at this.
-Domino's is getting inventive.
Their Australian account
posted this video
of them creating
a new summer-themed pizza.
The crust is actually made
of watermelon.
It's topped with tomato sauce
and pepperoni.
[ Ewwing and laughter ]
Honestly, I'd rather have
the pizza topped
with nuts and bolts.
Guys, whenever I get
some downtime here at the show,
I like to go on Instagram
and scroll
through all the photos
and one thing I've noticed is
that, a lot of times,
two people will write
the exact same caption,
but the pictures they post
will be completely different.
I'll show you what I mean
in this next segment.
It's time for "Picture This."
[ Cheering and applause ]
-♪ Picture this, picture this ♪
♪ Picture this ♪
♪ Yeah, picture this ♪
-Alright, let's take a look
at this first example.
It's from Ariana Grande
and Bernie Sanders.
[ Laughter ]
They both wrote...
...the Gmail login screen.
-Oh.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Hours.
-Hours?!
Just on the login screen.
-The next one is
from the CDC and the FDA.
They both wrote...
The pumpkin spice latte.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's already here.
Next one's from the UFC
and Organic Valley.
[ Laughter ]
They both wrote...
-Oh. Oh, no.
-Someone doing
the Milk Crate Challenge.
-Oh.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-This next one is
from Marvel and DC.
-Really?!
-They both wrote...
-Ooh.
-A Batman Popsicle
from some janky ice cream truck.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Yeah, sure, whatever, kid.
It's Batman.
-Hey, he's Batman, man.
[ Laughs ]
-Here's one
from Kamala Harris and Mexico.
-Ooh!
-They both wrote...
"Bachelor in Paradise."
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
This is the last one, here.
It's from Joe Biden and CVS.
They both wrote...
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's all the time we have
for "Picture This."